[Musique]
raconte moi conclut été au pays de
gibier
j'aurais tant parlé d'un arbre d'un arm
extra mutable savard et ont toujours toi
et moi je trouve au bas ou là
ohlala amiral vous est impossible dont
rêve est gay mais non je suis bien
éveillée et que vois-je
ça sent bien des trois forme d'un arbre
à droite sont pour vous il a bien mis
[Musique]
un banc de touche mon jeune ami et aux
îles pari mutuel la même ce que tout ça
n'était pas trop d'accord j'en suis
derrière les verts - venez nombreux
mentors gens rodant dit
j'ai l'impression que tu as faim au
d'héritage titus sous les regards des
maîtres mais le cas vous avez déjà vu à
lavera croient pas ou très intéressant
c'est très curieux au je ferai en
rapport à l'académie de botanique la
plus près cette est de mettre tout fait
trois ans en sécurité tu veux tous les
emporte tout parce que tu me grand yaka
allez voir il ne confisquera jamais
alors mon jeu la vie je le vois qu'une
solution remplit pas de poche je t'offre
le transport comme pas c'est pratique on
les entend alors tous les biens dans le
fond parce qu il ya de la place
le fait qu'elle a conservée dans le
réfrigérateur de mon score et tu es le
meilleur tu te promènes haye-pesnel que
c'est ma nuit
quoi qu'est ce qu'ils racontent titus
que compris toi d'être à 100 pour
gauriac à mettre melchior à une aide
d'un million de voix ne veut pas dire un
mot
j'ai comme ça oui oui ne peut pas parler
beau mais ça ne fait rien vu à montbard
melquiot mettre dessus que je veux c'est
que tu m'amuses me faisais quelques
tours de petites hésitations mais elle
est bon en fait venus tous les deux et
nous allons bien nous amuser tous les
trois elle et moi d'assumer stèles et je
regarde même si on sait peu comme s'ils
allaient alors puisque le mais le coeur
ne peut pas parler mais alors c'est toi
titus qui dira la formule magique à sa
place était fort est prêt mais prend mal
corps ou alors allez un jacta est
voyez le disais tu trembles il faut dire
l'acabit à québec et voilà ben voilà en
ferait une cidrerie iata c'est un joli 3
sans même vous détruisez musée un
atelier
bon allez mais le coeur tu fais autre
chose je vais te la deuxième fois à
tablier à tabac et voilà et c'est
d'entendre une fille c'est un très beau
coiffante mais c'est bien le cas si
jamais jean louis c'est pas mal beau
râler mais le cover troisième fois à
akabia cabaye et moira il est toujours
elle s'y fait c'est un magnifique
coffret oui mais oui même comme une
croix sur le fait n'est jamais vous vous
moquez de moi à mes clubs je suis
incapable de situer son complice et
morale est ce si cela apparaît vous de
mémoire vider son bec je veux tout voir
[Musique]
allons le voir là c'est mettre nos plans
et des crocs série éric est dit fier et
je n'aimais pas les faussaires et alors
vous allez voir ce que je vais faire
quoi
ceci cela elle est importé c'est quoi ça
au jardin et enterré les altérer les
tous
voilà vous ne les verrez plus que le
gommage des t-bonds coiffant le grand
yaka les m'a fait entrer soit en
barbares l'aude et d'europe
ignotus nous n'avons pas de chance de le
rencontrer au maître maintien est encore
un miracle quand c'est moi mais dont des
toros dhabi c'est de la botanique les
croissance mais on retouche ça ils ont
refait un autre à brax trois formes à
damgan la gamme et un trait après c'est
une autre histoire
[Musique]